ding or the land of the Thunderbolt is
home to India's finest tea but it may
not be so for long at least 10 of the
Region's 87 tea plantations have shut
down in recent years anaman canor a
planter who heads the tea exporters
Association says climate change Politics
the pandemic Global developments and
increasing costs are making it difficult
to continue every owner is in acute
financial crisis we have stayed afloat
because all of us who are in the ding
tea for us this is not a business you
know it's a passion uh we are in love
with our surroundings we are in love
with the TV produce the people who work
with us so for us this is an extended
family and that's what's keeping diling
Garden going so
far there are two main production
periods for daring tea October to early
March and may to June each year up to
80% of revenue is generated during this
time but but drought rain and falling
yields from aging t- bushers cut output
by more than half to 6,000 tons last
year known for its distinctive flavor
70% of this premium black tea has
usually been exported but global
economic problems and cheaper
alternatives from Nepal have hit demand
every year it's been getting worse worse
and
worse you only have
takers I mean of this tea during the
first first few months of the year after
which it's been a completely a whitewash
and that's been a trend ever since
2017 a 42% increase in Daily wages
fertilizer coal and chemical costs
coupled with falling demand has left
Planters unable to maintain their tea
plantations or replant the closures have
also hit thousands of workers and their
families the head of the Indian tea
Association Atul aana says urgent help
is needed if we can get a package of say
some kind of assistance for next 3 years
I'm sure we'll come back and the
government has to also take some
initiative to uh promote the teas and
tell the world that this is the these
the best other te are may be good but
not as good as
this Planters are hoping some help will
come their way so they can go on
producing India's Fame and aromatic tea
Min Fernandez Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer